Why the Adam’s Apple is Called the Adam’s
Apple
The origins of this term go all the way back
to the Biblical event where Eve gave Adam
a forbidden fruit, which is commonly misrepresented
as an apple.
The term then basically comes from the legend
that when he ate of the “apple”, the piece
got stuck in his throat and made a lump.
Now, of course, according to the Bible story,
it wasn’t an apple Adam and Eve ate of,
it was a fruit from the Tree of the Knowledge
of Good and Evil, of which there was apparently
only one.
Besides the obvious fact that I don’t know
anyone who’s felt particularly more knowledgeable
in the ways of good and evil when they ate
an apple, an apple tree is not self pollinating;
so you’d need more than one to have it produce
more of itself, which pretty firmly kills
the whole “apple tree” theory.
To make the origins of the term even more
ridiculous, even if it was an apple and it
got stuck in his throat, his children wouldn’t
somehow miraculously also have apples stuck
in their throats.
This is about as absurd as the age old “Well
if Adam had a rib taken out to make Eve, why
aren’t men missing a rib?”
Or the equally ludicrous corresponding claim
by many that men are somehow missing a rib.
Both sides of the argument seem to have suspended
all logic while arguing over this triviality.
The real irony here is the “rib” translation
was actually a mistranslation.
For more on that, see the Bonus Factoids.
So this all begs the question, why do most
people think the Bible says Adam and Eve ate
an apple to get them tossed out of the Garden
of Eden?
Why not an orange or a peach or why not just
call it like it is stated in the Bible story?
Well, Aquila Ponticus, who was a second century
translator translating the Old Testament from
Hebrew to Greek, took the liberty of translating
it as an apple tree, even though the original
text doesn’t say that.
It’s likely that he chose this due to the
fact that he was translating it into Greek
for Greeks and that in Greek mythology apples
were seen as symbols of desire
and destruction.